you
hello everyone we're glad you've joined
us for this live webinar strategies to
normalize mir ma expression in serum and
plasma i'm christy jewel elaborate and
i'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher calm
now let's get started you can submit
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're still fresh
in your mind to do so simply type them
into their drop-down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located in the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and the software's
free continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit we have
two speakers for you today speaking
first is Emily's arranger R&D staff
scientist sample preparations
Biosciences at Thermo Fisher Scientific
following Emily is doctor Haritha
bearish lingam senior product
application scientist
Thermo Fisher Scientific for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen Emily you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much and thank you again
to all of our attendees very glad to
have you here
as mentioned today we'll be talking
about strategies to normalize micro RNA
expression in serum plasma and just
briefly kind of on the agenda today the
first thing we'll cover is why micro RNA
why you would want to focus on this as a
research target then we'll move on to
when working with micro RNA the
challenges you kind of face working with
it and to being able to normalize its
expression analysis third will kind of
we'll talk about solutions and
strategies to address these challenges
to make it to make a seamless workflow
and working with micro RNA and then
finally we will move on to a question
and answer session where we can answer
any questions submitted so please don't
be shy
feel free to submit your questions to us
so first kind of going over use me why
you would want to focus on micro RNA
first reason is actually it's a very
well understood regulation pathway as
you can see from the schematic it's very
straightforward starting from the prime
micro RNA processing to pre micro RNA
then further into the mature micro RNA
once you reach the cytoplasm and then
from here the micro RNA will actually
regulate translation of message RNA
interesting about micro RNA is you can
have a single micro RNA can regulate
multiple messenger RNAs and then
multiple messenger RNAs can be regulated
by multiple micro rna's so
well-understood pathway with many points
in the pathway with potential for study
a couple of other key points which make
it a very interesting it's very well
conserved in eukaryotic organisms and do
all these factors it's very interesting
as far as human disease and actually
there have been documented cases a lot
of literature of the part micro RNA
plays at different points in this
pathway in human disease
as I mentioned multiple ways to study in
the pathway the pry micro RNA pre micro
RNA and mature micro RNA are all targets
for both extraction and detection
looking at what is upregulated or
downregulated disease versus normal in
addition you can also target the end of
the pathway and actually measure the
messenger RNA expression seeing if that
is upregulate or downregulated and then
trace that back to a particular micro
RNA or set of micro rna's again looking
for an impact in human disease and other
type of research focus
as I mentioned micro rna's very good
research subject for human disease one
of which is focused on micro RNA as
biomarkers do two kind of they're just
characteristics they actually make a
very good biomarker target and then also
a target for diagnostic screening
because of this and these
characteristics include they're small
they range from about eighteen to
twenty-two nucleotides so very few they
are relatively stable in their sample
matrix they do have protective
mechanisms for example extracellular
vesicles or protein complexes that
protect them from degradation they are
easily assayed both for sequencing and
real-time PCR as you can see there are
limited number of sequences they're
about two thousand total or less
documented and all of these are easily
detected by real-time PCR and sequencing
the third reason they're actually very
useful as biomarkers is they are very
present in liquid biopsy samples there's
been very much a movement towards liquid
biopsy as it's much easier took they're
much easier to collect and much less
invasive versus the traditional biopsies
and so all of these together make micro
RNA a very good candidate for biomarkers
and is such a very important area of
study
it's not going to moving on we've
determined that micro RNA very good
biomarker potential a very good research
target and focus however they are not
without their downsides one of which
being challenges to normalization micro
RNA is just due to their nature and
their pathway they do have a high
potential for expressions variability
some of these factors you can control
some of them can't always be controlled
and so you there are multiple areas
where you can address this normalization
both with the pre purification during
purification and then also when you
actually look at the data being able to
normalize that so the first two sample
type and doughnuts doughnuts um thing
you can control that's always variation
that's going to be around you can
however manage it with some of the tips
and tricks will present to you later in
the presentation but before I've
highlighted here the collection handling
the storage the purification method and
then the quantification and
qualification those actually do have a
little bit more things we can do to
control them standardize them to
improves consistency and reduce the
variation which leads to much easier
normalization
and so that leads us to our final
section where we will actually go over
the solutions and strategies to target
these four challenges that I've outlined
above and so included in solutions and
strategies the first is going over tips
and tricks for sample handling these
include the actual collection any
pre-processing steps and the storage of
the sample prior to RNA purification
after that we will focus on the RNA
purification and the importance of
reducing variation improving consistency
there I'll move on from there
to the ability to use an extraction
control as part of RNA purification one
more kind of control built in to reduce
variation and improve consistency and
from there I will hand it off to her
Rita who will speak to the
quantification of micro RNA with
real-time PCR and then also ways to
normalized my granny expression in the
real-time PCR data the first we'll go
over the sample handling tips and tricks
including collection pre-processing and
storage the first sample handling a lot
of variation we see micronet expression
can be traced back to inconsistent
upfront saintil hamplink Sandahl sample
handling excuse me and this includes the
initial collection the pre-processing
and these kind of steps can include for
example if you're collecting plasma the
first step is to collect the whole blood
and then a centrifugation step based
separation and so that's kind of one of
the pre-processing steps when I talk
about that that's what I mean and then
of course storage storing your sample
the biggest issue there of course being
is the concern of RNA degradation which
of course will change the expression
pattern of your micro RNA which is not
ideal and so the next few slides will
provide some guidance really the key in
all of our guidance is
- consistency and standardization the
more standardized your process more
consistent that easier it is to compare
results between four samples collected
between different labs samples analyzed
at different time so you can increase
your your sample size and get a better
answer and so that's kind of our focus
the first moving on to collection
collection of course as you can imagine
does it does make a difference what
sample type you're focusing on
collection protocols for example for
tissue would be a little bit different
than for serum plasma I've lifted listed
them all here I'm actually our focus of
our talk is much more towards near in
plasma so I will focus towards them but
the same kind of standardization
consistency rules do apply to the other
sample types so when you look at serum
and plasma is important your collection
device for example serum actually is
collected into your specific tubes that
makes it simple in that regard and then
your options are with or without
anticoagulants or co-activators both of
these work very well the idea though is
just to if you collect with one type of
tube keep that consistent over the
multiple studies as much as possible for
plasma again as I mentioned plasma is
generally first collected as whole blood
and then processed to separate the
plasma from the the other cell types in
the blood and what we generally
recommend are EDTA citrate or citrate
derivatives of the anticoagulants to use
in the tube we try to as much as
possible stay away from heparin because
it can cause a lot of problems for both
sequencing and real-time PCR and so the
EDTA citrate and citrate derivatives
tend to work much better
so now that you've got your sample
collected I mean I standardized process
for that then of course you moved to
pre-processing and as I mentioned before
these include any type of incubations
required mixing steps phase separation
again
the name of the game is standardization
and consistency when you're talking
about pre-processing again potential
variation comes from you know both
samples collected different labs each
lab might have its own kind of in-house
process and then of course between
different collections different
processing you may have variation from
that from you know from you do it on
Monday do to get on Wednesday there
could be variation there and then of
course variation between sample types
but each sample type will have kind of
its own method so if you're preparing
tissue to human plasma there's some
variation because of the different
methods obviously this is very
challenging you know when you have
collections for multiple labs so really
a solution to this as I said is
standardization and consistency so
rewrite we recommend development of your
own kind of standard process just to
keep everything you know everyone uses
the same system you know reduces the
variation quite a bit you can off there
are also available existing standard
processes and I've lifted an example
here from the early detection Research
Network for ATK plasma and serum so
there are multiple ones out there so
whichever method you choose really to
fit your particular need you just kind
of pick it and then stick with it and
that should help reduce your variation
and any variation in expression between
samples quite a bit and give you
confidence that any ziltch be are real
and can be untrustworthy so the final
part of sample handling of course is
sample storage again the idea really
with sample storage is to present
prevent RNA degradation as much as
possible because again if your RNA
degrades it can definitely change your
expression pattern and cause a lot more
variation make it that much more
difficult to normalize
again I've provided suggestions for
multiple sample types for you know again
really it's the idea of keeping it cold
keeping it cold prevents degradation in
and of itself and also prevents the
function of our nieces which of course
will degrade your sample much faster for
whole blood and tissue frozen - 70 or
colder is ideal you also have the option
of these two for using stabilizers RNA
later is typically one that we used and
that gives you more flexibility for both
temperature and time to a certain degree
unfortunately again we're focusing on
biofluids to your own plasma here
unfortunately the stabilizers don't work
as well for those but luckily for these
you have a little bit more flexibility
because micro RNA and bio fluids are
often protected by vesicles and protein
complexes you know again keep it cold
but you can store it at 4 degrees for a
little bit for the day and then minus 20
or minus 80 for longer periods of time
to prevent degradation
so now that we've covered kind of the
sample handling up front parts moving on
to RNA purification and I want a
purification again all of these
different parts to working with micro
RNA working with samples can have an
additive effect on any you know
variation collected each different
points and so limiting at each point
reduces that overall the are any
purification again if your system you're
using is not efficiently purifying or
extracting the micro rna's and that of
course will affect your expression
pattern and contribute quite a bit to
variation between samples so again that
is that is definitely the key point when
it comes to RNA purification
there are a lot of kids out there that
they just the reagents just aren't
optimal for the very small micro rna's
and so it is something to be aware of
other challenges to consider especially
when working with serum plasma is you
need to have a strong lysa step to
release the micro RNA these would be
from their protective for example extra
vesicle extracellular vesicles and
protein complexes and this can include
organic solvents mechanical lysis or
enzymatic lysis for example with
preemies k another challenge is if you
do need DNA free RNA make sure there's
some kind of DNA's treatment see where
the contaminating DNA is needed so
actually you know there are a lot of
methods out there extraction kits out
there which addressed these pretty well
organic base of course this is going to
be kind of your tries all type of
workflows very good for higher volumes
and for lower throughput if you just
have a few samples we also have a column
based methods these will be kind your
glass fiber based glass fiber filter
column methods Nirvana Paris is one that
we use these are great for kind of mid
volume input and then a low to mid
throughput these can also be combined
with an organic upfront
so you'll extract from the aqueous phase
and then finally we have met
McBee based systems these tend to use
more of the enzymatic lysis which is the
easiest to do for these type of methods
which are focused much more on high
throughput so these are going to be for
kind of more screening experiments where
you're looking at a low to mid volume
inputs but you're looking at a much
higher throughput so you can screen a
larger number of samples in order to
find potential biomarker and then save
the remaining volume of your sample and
do more extensive studies later on so
and I did this is actually I did want to
highlight for liquid samples such as
serum plasma these type of magnetic bead
based workflows or kits work the best
you know they have the enzymatic which
is very easy for liquid samples a lot
less time and effort required and here
actually I've demonstrated the workflow
with our mag Max Nirvana kit where you
take your serum plasma samples using the
kits and it is it's automation
instrument friendly so with our
kingfisher flex automation instrument
university your enzymatic digestion and
then you do your purification steps the
other nice thing about the kit includes
an a DNA's treatment within the
extraction method instead of having to
do it afterwards so it saves you time
the other nice thing is once you've
extracted your RNA it is easy you know
it's compatible with all downstream and
so you can take it directly from
extraction and put it into a downstream
workflow for example I've listed here
our real-time PCR workflow using our
attack main advanced system but you
could also go into a sequencing
application as well
and so these screens parents are pretty
useful and when you you know are looking
at the data you have a couple of options
so at the bottom I've shown some of our
data using our open array system with
the tach main advance which harita
actually will explain a little bit more
about the the technology and chemistry
behind that intersection but here you
can see it's querying you know a huge
number of microRNAs with several samples
and you are able to you know find the
targets that might be of interest and
then once you find a few of those then
you can actually kind of pull them out
and look at them more closely larger
number of samples with more of a single
tube or a rate card type of setup here
you can see looking at plasmasphere
examples kind of the CTS you get for the
different targets the whole workflow
very effective at extracting micro RNA
and kind of preserving that expression
pattern for multiple different types of
analysis
so now that you kind of have your RNA
purification method you like your
results look good you know you sometimes
it's good to double-check and so a lot
of people started kind of looking into
extraction controls to monitor recovery
and that's kind of what we've done here
it's there a good check to help with
normalization kind of a pre-check
step you know just to make sure that you
really extracted from your sample what
you plan to you know of course it's
difficult to quantify micro RNA as
expression can very highly you know even
in dodges endogenous micro RNA such as
Mayer 16 can fall victim to the kind of
the pre processing variation and so
having kind of an external control
eliminates the the any issues with that
synthetic micro RNA spike in is what we
found to be the best they need to have
some type of modification to prevent
degradation you know it'll be basically
naked RNA being spiked into your serum
plasma samples or other sample so it
will not be very protected from any RNA
TSA's and so these modifications will
will help protect them also they're
generally in known concentration so you
know how much you spike in and how much
you should get out we can use them
Nirvana micro RNA mimics but there are
other types of synthetic spike in and of
course you can make their own
but they fit very well into the workflow
it's pretty much you just combined it
with the serum plasma sample and put it
through the here I've pictured our Mad
Max mer Bona extraction workflow the
ones I use are generally non-human if
I'm working with human samples I prefer
to use a nonhuman spike in just in case
I don't want to have any you know if I
use a human micro RNA just in case that
micro RNA is expressed in my sample I
don't want that to kind of skew my
extraction control results and so here
I'm actually using two C elegans targets
which are pretty well known targets used
a lot in other types of research but
they fit in this workflow quite nicely
so I put it through the workflow and
then actually analyzed using both of our
micro RNA analysis our standard micro
RNA and then our newer attackman
advanced workflow and here you can see
two sets of data the bottom set focus on
first is I wanted to make sure you don't
want your your spike in to have any
effect on your actual target microRNAs V
the endogenous micro rna's or any micro
Arni's of interest in your sample and so
here you know - spike ins for both
plasma and serum multiple donors
compared to without a spike using the
standard chemistry you can see there's
no negative effect and so my um that's
what I want to see I want to see the
spike ins don't have any effect on an
endogenous sample and then here at the
top graph again you can see between the
multiple donors and the plasma and serum
there's really very little difference in
the CT values which is what you want in
a control so seven for for plasma and
serum works very well for Mara 39 plasma
serum excuse me is seems to work really
well for serum not so much for plasma so
you know really the the control you pick
depends on kind of your downstream need
but overall they work very well
and can fit kind of do what they need to
do as an extraction control and
demonstrate your RNA extraction method
works well I also did the attack main
advanced and again harita will kind of
explain the difference between the two
technology but very similar results for
these two for tagging advanced we also
do recommend some additional
modifications and five-prime
modifications to ensure best results
with the chemistry but very much like
the standard you can see minimal effect
to the no spike in control the
endogenous targets and similar results
looking at each one for the different
sample types
so at this point I will hand it off to
harita
to discuss our last two sections around
quantification and normalization alright
thank you so much Emily for that nice
overview of Sabbath recreation
collection and use of lighting controls
we will now shift gears and talk a
little bit about my travel made
detection and strategies for data
analysis including normalization to be
offer of several solutions for micro RNA
detection on the qPCR front there are
two distinct chemistry's that offered by
thermo Fisher these are the Tasman micro
RNA acids and attachment advanced micro
RNA acids
what are the pictorial representation of
their chemistry perspective chemistry
and let's look at tap on Mike Romney
acids so whatever my cornea is the
traffic mic Rodney acids rely on a my
progeny that's a big RT reaction in
which a stems of all t primer is used to
reverse transcribe my colony this is
followed by tagging assays to direction
rejected to detect sent my progeny
Takas advance micron i acid or the other
hand rely on what we call as the
universal C DNA synthesis in which all
micron is present in the sample are
simultaneously reverse transcribe this
process are facilitated by
polyadenylation at the three prime end
and adapter ideation at the five prime
end of each micro RNA following River
all my flora maesters in the sample also
undergo Universal mill anticipation and
at the end of the stage you would have
all my charm is grow trans price and the
ratified the next stage of this
chemistry is to detect specific micro
rna's using Tasmin advanced
microlearning acid both chemistry's
complement each other very well and
provide solutions
early about applications
definite Vance my progeny asses provide
superior sensitive sensitivity and an
ideal for analysis especially in serum
and plasma typical to study samples they
can detect as low as 60 input copies of
target Mike learning they also come in
with a very high specificity which
allows that to distinguish very closely
related colonies belonging to a single
family Universal of RT also allows you
to be able to study their study a large
number of my colonies with a very small
amount of input irony and of course they
come with the both time attachment asset
performance
there is a quick overview of to
chemistry's and the defense's so as I
spoke to happen microRNAs employ micron
is specific RT reaction whereas the
Batman advanced my progeny Asus employer
Universal reverse transcription each of
each of the assets have been designed
for my charm needs in their base the
most recent version which is version 22
we have over 200 we have Jasmine my
charming Asus 400 different species for
the advanced active however are
available for human mouse and rat
with respected reboot we recommend using
the TaqMan micro analysis for small
throughput studies where we're looking
for between the 1 and 10 different
targets and advanced assays are more
suitable for a higher throughput medium
to high throughput studies by looking at
either discovery validation or or
screening studies both our countries are
available in several different formats
single tube capillary card plates and
open early again facilitating a wide
array of applications
the different formats available for both
chemistry as I mentioned countries come
in different formats single tube as is
of course provides most flexibility they
are ideal for low throughput studies
very looking at a few samples and few
number of you targets such as
verification TaqMan array plates come
with pre spotted acids which are dry
down there ideas for small to medium
throughput analysis will enable you to
study anywhere from 1 to 96 samples on a
96-well plate or between one to three
hundred and eighty four different
samples in a 384 well plate the ideal
for verification and discovery Takanori
card also are pre spotted with acid they
I use for medium throughput analysis you
can investigate as many as one to eight
samples stored card and the ideal for
discovery and profiling
our highest tribute platform is the open
area plates which are also professional
asses you can investigate up to 48
different samples and these are ideal
sort of profiling a large providing
study you can see a very wide range of
product available to do a lot of
different applications
the moaning are normalizing my tribe
needs in a reverse transcription
quantitative PCR the purpose of any time
PCR experiment is to detect and measure
biological differences between samples
as far as process normalization is very
important because it reduces or removes
technical variability between samples to
ensure that the observed differences are
only due to biology there are many
different ways that normalizes applied
to data analysis popular omentum are
global mean normalization use of
endogenous or reference my progeny and
use of spiking control the glottal mean
normalization as we all know is
essentially employed when the number of
targets that are being studied is large
so anywhere from you know couple of
hundred to a thousand targets being
studied can employ the visualization so
applications of the renormalization
would be profiling or discovery spiking
controls have a dual role as Emily spoke
about using them for ad extraction and
processing control it can also be used
as controls for both the motors controls
Estanza stand-alone controls as well as
controls to help identify an option
where i'm going to talk about in a few
slides and of course the classic way of
normalizing gene expression analysis is
using reference or endogenous controls
and these are controls which are known
to be stable expressed across the sample
set applications for of reference
controls would be providing discovery
and verification
and in order to demonstrate some of
these normalization techniques we
investigate a differential expression of
genes in CLL chronic lymphocytic
leukemia matched normal and diseased
plasma samples from donor donors
identified with CLL were obtained and
put to the entire workflow starting with
sample preparation where are we was
extracted using the max the wanna total
RNA isolation kick the RNA would reverse
transcribe using the TaqMan advance
microRNAs serine essence of kit followed
by qPCR on the opener a human advanced
micro RNA pandal the open era of human
advanced panel consists of unique 755
mitral make passes and allows you to
investigate up to 3 and 3 different
samples on on a single rate
these can be run on a quantity of 12 K
flex system and data analysis was done
on thermal fisher of connect using the
RQ app
analysis we selected a global
normalization in the analysis setting
you ad and what this algorithm does is
it identifies targets which are common
to all samples in the study and
identifies CQ me a CQ median of all of
these targets and uses it as
normalization factor for all the samples
and what you end up with is data which
is been normalized
using global normalization and here
you're looking at a heat map of gene
expression where normalization has been
done using global mean normalization
across the four different samples that
were used in this study so we had to
disease and two normal samples and you
can see that the data is captured by
disease there was really good
differentiation of gene expression
change the disease and normal samples
which is what was expected from the
sample set
the next most popular strategy to
normalize micronation expression is to
use endogenous controls or reference
genes however my progeny is actually
pretty difficult or it's challenging to
find endogenous controls or repetitions
because it's known that my Harney
expression greatly varies between
tissues between the different issues as
well as body fluid and therefore there
is no uniformly expressed my progeny
which can be used as a candidate
reference gene across or tissues and
they especially more difficult to find
in dispersed sample particular plasma
historically snow ironies Etten rnase
and u6 have been used as reference
endogenous controls however more recent
literature suggests that they're
probably not the ideal reference or
endogenous controls because the follow
of the mechanism by which the the
biomolecules and the site is very
different from that of my colony the
price is different so a lot of these
could be degraded or you know
differentially expressed in disease
versus normal tissue to be we are moving
away from that recommendation of using
snows or snrnas as reference controls
further if the sensor to find at least
two or three different reference genes
that are steadily expressed in your set
of samples because that is a mighty
guideline you know to normalize data
again it's not just a single but at
least a group of microRNAs
um in the next few slides I'm going to
talk about a methodology to
systematically identify a group of
stabili Express micron names in a given
set of samples which could then be
exploited as reference microRNAs
to demonstrate that we use the same set
of samples used for a global mean
normalization and after our an
extraction of from plasma our neighbors
fighting with of fighting with no
synthetic are a target which was the
Cystic on a target for C elegans merge
39 3 P this mixture of Army and spike in
exogenous control was then reverse
transcribe using Pakistani acid which
would then load it on or you know in the
loaded on to the tackle advanced my
chlorinate human endogenous control cart
the human endogenous control arrays are
available both in in the card format as
well as plate format and the consist of
30 unique micro RNA target and - so it's
the 30 unique my client is a human and
then we have two non human targets on
their ceiling and 39 3p and an Arab
adopters target these 1330 my progeny
are known to be a Sibley expressed
across the different tissues and fire
fluids and this information is based out
of literature and we using cash to
identify reference genes in our set of
samples the cuts are run either on one
studio system or the vf7 system and data
analysis was again done on thermo Fisher
connect using the RQ app and this time
around we used the data and alpha
setting was set to normalization using
spiking control between the second
option on data analysis and what did we
find
but we found that off the 30 micron name
on the card there was three that were
consistently expressed in all the four
samples which were part of our studies
so these were HSN where 19 3 a 1983 be
HSM air for 451 E and H SML 59 party
and we identified these as dress and
jeans in our set samples
so once the reference genes are
identified the next step is to use them
as endogenous controls in your study
which would be a much larger study here
is a screenshot of the thermo Fisher
connect app with the rqf showing
expression of reference genes right so
you're looking at expression levels of 3
reference genes in the insect samples
and you can see that they consistently
expressed the algorithm here also
presents scores for each of these
targets and a lower score indicates that
the target is a good reference tree
once things have been identified the
next step is use them as endogenous
controls in your new larger study so for
the purpose to demonstration again we
used the mash normal disease plasma
samples from donors identify that CLL
and they were put through the same
workflow as earlier and in this case we
potato analysis we set in the RQ app as
settings were set to endogenous controls
and the three targets that were
identified in previous study were set as
endogenous controls what did we find
so we compared differential gene
expression between the four samples on
when they were normalized by globally
normalization and when they were
normalized by reference genes and deform
excellent concordance of data between
the two
suggesting that both of these strategies
are reliable strategies just pay
attention keep in mind that global mean
normalization is recommended for targets
or for high-throughput studies when at
least a couple of hundred targets are
being investigated
whereas resolutions can be used for you
know any number of targets there's no
restriction so that's the advantage of
using of identifying endogenous or
I also wanted to bring that that why in
this study we have done a lot of the
analysis or not experiments on our open
area platform similar study can be done
on both Takanori cards as well as
Takanori traits the same number of
targets which are present on opener a
platform are also available on takanori
cards and plate for investigation and
you will see very comfortable data
between the three platforms
this brings me to the end the tea
observations from this NL analysis you
will see that there are many many
aspects of learning analysis which can
have a huge impact on the outcome of a
differential expression starting from
samples you know the method methodology
is used for sample collection sample
storage RNA extraction the technology
which is used to detect my colony the
various formats which are used for
providing discovery and verification and
finally data normalization which can
challenge in my progeny qPCR analysis
however we provided a lot of tools and a
lot of strategies for you for you to be
able to refer normalize your data in
difficult samples such as serum and
plasma
again double mean organization is a good
strategy of it is in profiling and
discovery studies we're looking at hydro
put and in our in our experiments we
found no matter which strategy you use
as long as the technique to identify
reference chain is is reliable then you
would get good concordance between the
different strategies used to normalize
my car and extract data with that it's
time to take some questions
Thank You Emily and harita for your
presentation it is time for our live Q&A
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions just click on that
ask a question box over there on the far
left of your screen and we will answer
as many questions as we have time for
okay our first question Emily let's
start with you
Emily what's the recommended sample
volume input for the RNA purification so
it is going to depend on kind of what
method you're using for example if
you're using an organic extraction
something like the Nirvana Paris kit
your inputs going to be anywhere from
two hundred to four hundred microliters
of serum plasma however if you're using
more of kind of a screening tool or bead
based for example the mag max Nirvana
kit your inputs going to be 100 to 200
minus
Thank You Emily harita let's move over
to you can I use you six or other small
non-coding RNAs as endogenous control
all right so historically allows these
non-coding RNAs other than micron names
were used to add reference genes to
normalize my colony expression however
decent more recent research and
suggestiveness have suggested that
they're probably not the best candidate
endogenous controls because they don't
represent micron expression divergences
very different their sizes are very
different and also a lot of these small
non-coding rnas have been found to
differentially regulated in these
samples step technique answer so while
there's competition with nominees at
refuse controls more recent research
suggests that that's probably not the
best endogenous control
Thank You harita and lay back over to
you I like the extraction control idea
but I prefer to use a different Mir ma
as my control
is this an option and if so what would
be your suggestions for confirming it
will work with my samples
okay yes you can definitely use if you
have a micro RNA that you would prefer
to use as your control um you definitely
can my stove elegans I'd worked with
them before and I knew they worked
really well I would caution being
careful if you are using a human micro
RNA as your extraction control just
because there's always potential if
you're working with human samples even
if you know I know some mark RNA or for
tissue some found in specific tissue
some are in fear and plasma some in
blood and not in the other even if
that's the case there is always a chance
that they might be detected and so they
could kind of throw off your extraction
control values in again so just be you
know kind of careful of that and what I
was just kind of the approach I took is
I actually looked at multiple different
targets and it kind of a titration of
input into my sample I believe I went
all the way down
Kika grams up to five nanograms to find
especially for PCR you know you want to
make sure that your CT values aren't a
good you know rain machine Oh 15 to 20
is kind of what I look for and so just
kind of titrate you know kind of what
input fits best in that range I would
also make sure to multiple donors and
also look at both serum and plasma
because those two sample types although
very similar can also be very different
and between different donors you can
also get a lot of variation and so you
want to make sure that your control is
unaffected kind of like in the
presentation you saw the de7 for your
plasma different donors kind of traffic
distance CT value that's what you'd want
to look for and so you do want to make
sure to test a large number of samples
to confirm that before you move on to
kind of your your important signal
Thank You Emily now looks like we have
time for one last question
Karina will come back to you what
strategy can be used to normalize mi
RNAs from exomes
um so exosomes of blacks humans asthma
we recommend using a lot of strategies
that were discussed in the presentation
if the number of targets that you are
looking at is large so a hybrid study
then ideally
globerman organization is an option
secondly of just light concealment and
identifying two or three controls or
reference streams which are stable
expressed in your set of samples and
they would work as either as reference
streams and would be ideal endogenous
controls for your sample set
emmeline harita thank you again Jemmy
final comments for our audience
yes but I would like to say that we of
you know as Emily and I went through the
presentation we have workflow solutions
for every stage of micron my analysis
please take a look at all the products
that are offered and feel free to reach
out to em if you have questions on any
of those or any of the material that has
been presented today in the webinar
Thank You harita and Emily both of you
thank you for your time today and for
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webinar
before we go I would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through August 2009
teen labret will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks for joining us
until next time goodbye